[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
desde el año 2000 Israel ha detenido y
juzgado a más de 12.000 palestinos de
entre 12 y 18 años con una
particularidad como potencia ocupante
Israel procesa estos jóvenes de forma
automática a través de la ley militar
este caso único en el mundo es enunciado
de forma recurrente por las
organizaciones pues las autoridades
infligen a los menores maltratos físicos
y psicológicos y sistemáticos en el
proceso a los jóvenes palestinos se les
ve afectado el normal desarrollo y de la
infancia o adolescencia con daños en su
educación y su relación con la familia y
el entorno hoy tenemos a Federico cueva
verena y a Yanira Gómez autores de este
reporteros les saludo a ambos Federico
Por qué los menores palestinos son
juzgados solo por ley militar y bajo Qué
motivos
según la convención de Ginebra Israel
como potencia ocupante aplica a la ley
militar en los territorios palestinos y
solo bajo esa normativa deben ser
procesados también los menores lo
contradictorio es que en el mismo
territorio ocupado Israel aplica dos
sistemas el militar para los palestinos
y el civil para los colonos israelíes de
los asentamientos ilegales para la ley
internacional sobre los motivos Israel
se escuda en una amplia definición de
seguridad para encarcelar a los menores
y el cargo principal es el de arrojar
piedras e incluso si el resto es de tipo
administrativo como vamos a ver ahora ni
siquiera Explica el porqué pero para las
organizaciones que consultamos el
objetivo de fondo es garantizar el
control israelí sobre los palestinos y
esto se ve en que la mayoría de los
arrestos de menores ocurren o en zonas
cercanas a los asentamientos o donde
Israel elige el muro de separación y de
hecho en ocasiones son detenidos en
medio de la calle
Gracias Federico ya volvemos con Yanira
veamos la historia
[Música]
en el cuarto de said se observan las
marcas de dos infancias una de
calcomanías y otra de puertas forzadas
por el ejército de Israel que lo arrestó
en su décimo quinto cumpleaños
cuando escuché los movimientos y el
ruido me desperté aterrorizado Quién
viene hasta ahora en el reloj eran
exactamente las 2:50 de la mañana eran
los soldados israelíes los vi me
pregunté a mi edad que quieren estas
personas de mí
un ejército armas gritos estaban en
posición de tiro
ese 10 de septiembre de 2019 said se vio
rodeado de soldados que lo aislaron de
su familia por presunto lanzamiento de
bombas Molotov notaron las manos y me
aventaron los ojos aunque no podía ver
como crecía aquí sentía que me llevaban
a la torre militar empezamos a caminar
entre los olivos el soldado israelí que
me sostenía me llevó adrede a través de
las piedras y cactus para que me hiciera
daño
en esta casa han sufrido más de 20
redadas y la detención de tres de cuatro
hijos pero la de said fue particular
Porque siendo el menor estuvo preso 16
meses la mayor parte en pandemia
puedes imaginar que como musulmanes
cuando ayunamos en ramadán seguimos
ritos especiales
fue muy duro para nosotros porque no
teníamos a tres de nuestros hijos
cada año Israel detiene y procesa a
entre 500 y 1000 palestinos menores de
18 años con el cargo más común de
arrojar piedras mientras los menores
israelíes son juzgados bajo un sistema
civil sus pares palestinos son los
únicos en el mundo en ser
automáticamente procesados en cortes
militares dos normas nos diferencian en
cisjordania que como territorio ocupado
se rige por ley militar
organizaciones denuncian que la ley
militar israelí no garantiza derechos
juveniles e incurre maltratos
sistemáticos Durante los interrogatorios
said pasó 10 días en confinamiento
solitario práctica con unicef desaprueba
en menores
al principio te dejan en una pequeña
celda la cama apenas alcanza para
acostarte
los soldados israelíes se tienden a
hacer mucho ruido se empeñan en hacerte
sentir incómodo luego te someten a
largas horas de interrogatorios
se esfuerzan por acostarte y presionarte
para que confieses que hiciste algo
cuando en realidad no hiciste nada
dos tipos de interrogatorios El más duro
lo aplica la inteligencia israelí que él
califica de no oficial El otro lo
efectúa a la policía que es el que queda
registrado
al final te dicen Qué hiciste y dijiste
y tienes que firmar un papel
estaban escritos en hebreo y luego
Israel usa estas confesiones en tu
contra para sentenciarte
los soldados dicen que tratan mejor a
los menores pero no es verdad si entras
en una prisión israelí eres un
prisionero y no les importa si eres un
menor o un adulto
los soldados israelíes afirmaron que Yo
solía tirarles cócteles Molotov Y eso no
era verdad
[Música]
International palestine lleva 30 años
documentando casos como el de said en
agosto de 2022 el ejército allanó y
clausuró su oficina luego de que Israel
sin presentar pruebas la catalogara de
organización terrorista
aquí y aquí también la sellaron
Así que está cerrado
el objetivo principal es desacreditar a
la organización y evitar que operemos
sobre todo a nivel internacional
porque una parte de nuestro trabajo es
exponer las vulneraciones y relieves
contra niños palestinos en los
territorios ocupados
ilegalizada por Israel dice hay
palestine continúa su labor arrinconada
en una sala de otra ong que por
seguridad no nos permiten Mostrar
en esta situación temen desaparecer y
dejar sin ayuda legal gratuita a las
familias que reportan un mismo patrón
Menores arrestados en horas de la noche
que no son informados de sus derechos ni
de los sitios de traslado a los que
llegan vendados sin acceso previo a un
abogado tutor
la mayoría de los niños palestinos son
arrestados por lanzar piedras pero el
objetivo es suprimir y controlar
cualquier resistencia contra las
políticas israelíes en los territorios
ocupados
la ley militar israelí castiga lanzar
piedras con Entre 10 y 20 años de cárcel
sin embargo la mayoría de los menores
son recluidos desde varias semanas hasta
un año porque firman acuerdos de
culpabilidad para terminar lo antes
posible el encarcelamiento Israel
no respeta sus obligaciones bajo las
convenciones internacionales sobre todo
bajo la convención de los derechos del
niño que sostiene que el arresto de
menores Debería ser una medida de último
recurso y por el periodo de tiempo más
corto y apropiado
ellos mantienen a los niños detenidos
durante todo el proceso así que el
principio de presunción de inocencia no
está cuando los procesan a través del
sistema legal militar de Israel
en prisión aguardanas su padre aún
ignora porque su hijo de 17 años fue
arrestado en marzo de 2022 por la
inteligencia israelí cuando los soldados
israelíes vinieron a llevarse a anas
intentaron romper la puerta
tenían una palanca de metal de este lado
quedó arruinada del otro no
abrí
entraron con sus armas y fueron directo
hacia annas
sabían dónde estaba estaba en su cama
le pregunté al oficial los cargos y me
dijo que los habríamos luego Y hasta
ahora no hay cargos
con esperanza la familia de anas
mantiene intacta su cama con sus
cigarrillos y teléfono su regreso En
cambio es incierto porque está bajo
detención administrativa
Esto fue durante la boda de su hermano
Este es sanas le echamos mucho mucho de
menos la detención administrativa es una
reclusión sin cargos ni juicio que se
puede renovar sin límites y se basan
razones de seguridad en este caso sólo
sabidas por Israel la familia cree que
anas fue incriminado por celos por su
éxito como pintor Pues en el pasado
alguien lo acusó de querer crear un
grupo armado si bien la denuncia no se
probó la inteligencia Palestina lo
retuvo dos semanas
la inteligencia Palestina lo golpeó y
ahora cuando le pregunté a anas por el
trato de los oficiales israelíes me
explicó que lo golpearon y lo torturaron
unas horas de 2 a 11 de la mañana anas
permaneció en un Jeep nueve horas
maniatado y con los ojos tapados vivimos
bajo dos ocupaciones de Israel y la
autoridad Palestina
se encuentra en la cárcel de mellido que
como la cárcel de damón se ubica en
Israel a estas dos son transferidos más
del 60% de los menores palestinos lo que
obliga a los padres a tramitar permisos
de entrada a Israel para cada visita
mensual
es una tragedia gastar tu vida entre
prisiones yendo a visitas obteniendo
permisos y ser humillado en el proceso
no es el único que está preso somos diez
en esta casa y todos somos prisioneros
estamos emocionalmente exhaustos
realmente sufrimos mucho Siempre estoy
pensando dónde duerme que come
en sus años al mando de la fiscalía
militar moris Hills procesó a cientos de
menores palestinos tras servir 19 años
en el ejército él sostiene que Israel
emplea la ley militar y el arresto
administrativo de acuerdo al derecho
internacional
Israel no arresta a niños ese es un
planteamiento erróneo Israel arresta a
terroristas a personas que han cometido
ofensas contra la ley eso pasa en
cualquier país del mundo y algunos de
ellos son menores de 18 años
la creación de un tribunal juvenil es
uno de los pocos cambios que Israel ha
introducido en la ley militar también el
uso de precintos plásticos en arrestos
de menores Pero según las ong adamir y
Military kur watch ambas medidas
incumplen en su mayoría y en el caso de
las tintas son apretadas de más causando
Cortes y moretones
no puedes usar esposas de metal porque
eso ya era el niño no puedes usar
precintos plásticos porque eso los
lastima también qué habría que hacer
darle un certificado que diga eres un
buen odiador de judíos y dejar de oír
el cumplimiento de la ley en cualquier
país del mundo no es placentero es lo
que es
ser soldado en el terreno transformó
aiman de familia militar en sus tres
años de servicio obligatorio en la
unidad de francotiradores detuvo a
menores e irrumpió en casas palestinas
como nos muestra en sus imágenes
Hoy junto a otros exmilitares condena y
expone la ocupación israelí
como ocupación militar necesitamos
Mostrar fuerza y control
Ese es el objetivo de muchos de los
arrestos yo resté a muchísimas personas
que no hicieron nada así que los niños
palestinos creo que son un objetivo
fácil para que los comandantes de las
fuerzas israelíes muestren que el
sistema funciona
relata que una vez Recibió la orden de
arrestar a un joven de 16 años por
supuestos lazos con un grupo terrorista
detención que consideró innecesaria
él estaba muy asustado No puedes
imaginarte lo que estaría pensando
todo eso pasó porque quizás habló con
alguien por internet y no fuimos con una
orden de arresto solo con un nombre
pero para nosotros no había diferencia
entre ese Adolescente y el mayor
terrorista que hayamos conocido
esta experiencia altera por completo la
vida de los menores
pasen días o meses el trauma físico y
emocional de haber estado en prisión les
crea barreras una de ellas es la
interrupción del año escolar mientras
unos deciden recuperar las clases otros
abandonan los estudios y se refugian en
cursos vocacionales App del raman asiste
hoy a su primera sesión tras pasar tres
meses encarcelado
me privaron de ir a la escuela solía ir
pero luego Israel me arrestó y ya no voy
más tengo muchos amigos que son
albañiles cuando vi el oficio me gustó y
decidí aprenderlo
detrás del acceso a estos cursos está la
ong cristiana y Jerusalén que cuenta con
un programa de asistencia educativa y
psicológica con el que reintegra a
menores ex detenidos cuando metes a un
niño en prisión metes en prisión a toda
una generación su tiempo en prisión les
dice que ya no son niños que de alguna
manera son hombres y mujeres cuerpos de
niños Así que salen traumatizados con
daños psicológicos severos
nuestros niños merecen ser niños
pensando que el cielo es su límite no el
muro no los Checkpoints no las rejas
con ejercicios Mara asistenta social
Busca liberar estrés y expandir la
seguridad de estos adolescentes de cada
uno conoce Si sufre depresión estrés
postraumáticos y presentó cambios en su
comportamiento o duerme mal por las
noches
en grupo les ayuda a lidiar con estas
secuelas y a volver a relacionarse en
comunidad
azan aún no se siente seguro para ir a
casa de sus abuelos hacia Allí se
dirigía cuando los soldados israelíes lo
arrestaron en plena calle entonces días
de detención lo golpearon varias veces y
lo amenazaron con encarcelar a toda su
familia
muchos trabajadores sociales y
terapeutas me ayudaron a superar mi
trauma a desarrollarme tomé clases de
inglés comencé a estudiar de nuevo me
gustaría estudiar abogacía y Derechos
Humanos para defender a los niños
palestinos presos en Israel vuelvo a
anhelar cosas pero lo que me pasó es
inolvidable como niño de 14 años Fue muy
duro nunca lo voy a olvidar
el deseo de estudiar una carrera une a
azale con Said a ojos de su madre esos
16 meses tras las rejas lo han vuelto
más nervioso pero no le han quitado su
determinación
no hay aspectos positivos de esta
experiencia pero te hace ver la vida
diferente
a quienes dicen que los niños palestinos
son terroristas no no lo somos no somos
terroristas queremos vivir
vivir sin miedo a ser encarcelados ese
es el anhelo de la juventud Palestina
estamos de vuelta con Yanira Gómez
Yanira que otro tipo de violencia
enfrentan los menores palestinos
en este reporteros vemos algunas
vulneraciones durante el arresto y el
encarcelamiento pero no son las únicas
las denuncias van desde detención de
menores para sacarles información sobre
sus familiares o vecinos hasta
agresiones sexuales por supuesto los
menores palestinos sufren la ocupación
israelí como los adultos si no son
ajenos a controles redadas o bombardeos
que muchos casos les causan la muerte y
así ha sido para más de 50 solo en este
2022 de ahí que el padre de said nuestro
primer testimonio nos confesará que
prefirió ver a su hijo preso antes que
muerto pero volviendo a nuestro enfoque
en 2013 unicef concluyó que el sistema
de detención israelí es abusivo tiene
malas malos tratos malas prácticas de
manera sistemática generalizada e
institucionalizada hacia los menores y
le hizo una serie de recomendaciones
pero más allá de algunos retoques diez
años después su conclusión sigue vigente
Gracias Yanira y Federico por
acompañarnos hoy hasta aquí reporteros
en la semana recuerde que para
sintonizar esta y las emisiones
anteriores puede visitar nuestro sitio
web France 24.com hasta la próxima
[Música]